president Trump's announcement that the
US would halt funding to the World
Health Organization draws criticism the
biggest US airlines and the Treasury
reached an agreement in principle on
financial aid and South Korea
experiments with holding an election
during a pandemic
I'm Shelby Holiday and here's what you
need to know today
we have an investigation underway on the
World Health Organization we will find
out exactly what went on president
Trump's announcement that the US would
freeze funding to the w-h-o has drawn
criticism from some health experts
politicians and other personalities with
Bill Gates saying such a move during a
major health crisis is as dangerous as
it sounds
Democratic Senator Chris Murphy accused
Trump of attempting to deflect attention
from his fatal mishandling of this
crisis United Nations chief Antonio
Guterres denounced the cut and said now
is not the right time to look into how
the virus spread so rapidly Trump
faulted the UN agency for in his view
acting too slowly and making mistakes in
managing the pandemic a senior
administration official said the u.s.
provided more than 450 million dollars
to the w-h-o in the 2019 fiscal year
u.s. politicians and the White House
have disagreed over whether Trump can
withhold w-h-o funds without
congressional approval officials said 10
of the 12 biggest US airlines agreed to
the terms of a rescue package with the
Treasury Department the financial aid
includes 25 billion dollars to help
prevent layoffs and allow employees to
continue receiving benefits Delta United
American and others have been hit hard
by the pandemic and slashed flights by
upward of 70 percent the money will come
with certain conditions for example
airlines won't be allowed to lay off or
furloughed workers involuntarily until
October
South Korea moved ahead with its
national legislative election today the
first in a country that was deeply hit
by the pandemic voters were required to
stand three feet apart at Cape marked
spots get their temperatures taken then
sanitize their hands and wear gloves
before casting their votes president
moon jae-in's popularity has surged
after his nation's successful
coronavirus response and his party is
expected to keep control of the National
Assembly
[Music]